oh
elle
[Musique]
à
donc là par exemple on est sur un
diagnostic qui précède une opération
immobilière au 3 rue des fauchés orléans
et lors de ce diagnostic on a trouvé
notamment d une sépulture du
du haut moyen-âge en fin de l'antiquité
tardive plus précisément qui vient
recoupez qui vient remplacer une
occupation romaine comme l'a mis au jour
sous la forme d'un petit scellier donc
d'un petit au creusement quadrangulaire
qui est d une petite cave en route d'une
maison romaine en fait la volonté de
présenter cette carte interactive
c'est né de la volonté de restituer les
connaissances qu'on acquiert sur les
fouilles archéologiques tous les jours
et de pouvoir en fait montrer aux
habitants dans les ans que là où il
habite en fait il ya autre chose que les
rues actuelle et c est que sous leurs
pieds en fait on peut avoir des vestiges
beaucoup plus anciens et donc ça permet
de resituer en fait ces vestiges assez
proches les habitants
[Musique]
c'est de montrer comme quoi
l'archéologie n'est pas qu'un frein en
fait à l'aménagement elle accompagne
l'aménagement bien en amont quand c'est
possible et qu'il ya des résultats
probants qui se font et qui peuvent
effectivement conduire à mieux connaître
sa villa à mieux percevoir le patrimoine
et à le préserver
le cas échéant lorsque une construction
qui peut être légèrement déplacé par
rapport à la connaissance que l'on a du
sous-sol enfin ça on est là aussi aussi
pour ça pour montrer comme quoi
l'archéologie n'est pas qu'un frein